I can imagine
um so you're gonna be popping up in a
company with someone to be like buddy
you're too old like what are you doing
it's over it's not though how old are
you I'm 40 years old come on man you're
you're probably Superior 40 years old
you can you can you can absolutely yeah
um so you're gonna be popping up in 32
30 days exactly yeah exactly 40 who
plays 30. yeah um you're gonna be
popping up in She-Hulk you need to back
off and waste this outfit Eugene get out
of here go super soon you're making a
mistake you made a mistake when you
messed with my client because now I'm
gonna whoop your ass I had a really fun
time with Tatiana and the chemistry
between those two characters was so much
fun and the back of four we got to see a
new side of of Matt murder you know we
got to see a side to him of him where
he's kind of like you know
enjoying his role and having fun and
flirting and and so it'd be you know we
gonna go that one episode so I'd be
really cool if she was to come and maybe
do a little Arc in our show
um so that would be really cool I kid
you not when you came out somebody in
the pressroom here I was like
that's sweet it is I mean what does it
feel like to know that your Daredevil
made such an impact on people that was
literally like the only thing people
want to talk about in terms of any of
these projects they're like yeah but is
Daredevil in this one I I don't you know
I'm horrified by any kind of form of
flattery it's like it's a little
embarrassing so when you get a reaction
like that it's like it just feels
surreal like you can't quite imagine it
um so yeah I feel really emotional it's
it's a it's a bizarre experience to have
played this character to have the
experiences I've had with this with this
character and the journey that we've
been on with the show for that to be
finished and ended and it's in my mind
and heart it's over and then to be
yanked back in and suddenly we're
starting again and it's all happening
again and it feels like a dream it feels
a bit like a dream popping up an echo
and then dick are you I don't know I
thought that was
great apparently I'm gonna Echo am I
that's what I've heard I thought that
was confirmed I heard that okay but we
are confirmed for Daredevil born again
we are which is what 18 episodes yeah
that's mad isn't it that is yeah um
can you what do you know about that what
have you guys started to know what
everyone else knows which is a great
feeling because I can't spoil anything
um I met some of the writers last night
for the first time I haven't read
anything
um I'm psyched to discover how they're
gonna what stories they're gonna tell
over that long period of time tonally
what it's going to be like how is it
different how is it how is it the same
you know Kevin has been very clear about
it being season one so not a season four
you know so it's it's an it's a whole
new deal
um and in a way that's what's great
about that is that we potentially get to
tell some of the stories over and over
again yeah um in the same way that they
do in the comics you know every now and
again they stop back at the beginning of
Murdoch's Journey as a little boy and
they tell the whole origin story again
so maybe we'll get to do that I don't
know what would it like for you to get
back together with Vincent it's uh you
know so him and I are now like you know
dear friends and we've gone through this
experience together and he was like can
we can you believe we're here and I
remember I was reminded of a
conversation I called him during covet I
called him from my house
and we were chatting and he was like
this is two years later
and he was like this I'm sure we're
going to do something with us they're
definitely gonna and I was like buddy
you are it's over Bud you've got to let
it go you're mad they're definitely not
it's been two years you know I was
trying to like trying to help him out I
was like yeah wake him up you know what
I mean Kevin talked about the street
level heroes and now Spider-Man is a
part of that world I know this is like
way cart before the horse but would you
like you would obviously like to team up
with Spider-Man and Tom Holland at some
point right yeah who cares
yeah I mean like that's the dead of the
the Matt Murdock Peter Parker stuff
there's is a treasure Trove of stuff to
to unpack
um and we just got that little moment
you know so yeah look it's difficult I
have no idea what they're thinking I
don't I don't know where I'm gonna find
the time yeah because I'm doing 18
episodes of the show is there anybody
else that you want to have now that
you're I would love to do that sandbox
who do you who else do you want to play
with I don't know what the rules are
yeah yeah always so I don't know I'm
probably speaking out of term but like
um you know Tom hiddleston's one of my
best friends it'd be so cool if he even
if he just kind of shows up holding a
Tesla out for a minute and then he's
gone again you know that'd be really fun
but I don't know it's like all these
toys that you want to play with and
which ones are we allowed
foreign